Congratulations.
You should be extremely proud
of the work you've accomplished.
Can you believe that a short time ago
Angular was this other worldly entity?
Now not only have you worked through
a lot of Angular's complicated concepts
like scopes and services.
But you've built several
applications in Angular.
We've been discovering
what Angular offers and
how it works I encourage you
not to stop here though.
There's so much more to angular that
makes it a fantastic framework.
Go on and learn about the differences
between services and factories.
The application bootstrap cycle.
The details of two way data binding by
looking at how Angular Digest works.
And creating your own custom directives.
Let me know what you find.
What are you still doing here?
Go build something amazing.
In the next lesson we'll
be taking a look at Ember,
a framework that helps you build
ambitious web applications.
Come back and check it out.